I really pray about the Fedbed is all protocol.
Are there any negatives to try it or can I just add it to my current supplement protocol?
So again, and I test everybody on this, so if I did recommend it,
again, if you feel like I'm leading you to do this Fedbed protocol,
can it be something you can try? Okay, so in general, the Fedbed protocol is not going to
interfere with any current protocol you're doing, except there's a caveat. So Fedbed is all
as a drug and Fedbed is all, I mean, we've been using Fedbed is all and having people on
Fedbed is all for, you know, quite a few years now. And I'll be the first to tell you that there
are some side effects to it that you have to keep an eye on it. You have to, you have to be doing
a complete metabolic protocol, a complete metabolic panel blood test on a very regular basis
if you're going to do Fedbed is all because Fedbed is all can be hard on your liver and you can get
an elevation of AstLT and alkaline phosphatase. And if that goes up and if that spikes up,
that's inflammation in your liver, and you could damage your liver, you got to go off
with Fedbed is all for a period of time till those numbers call back down and then you can do it again.
So, Fedbed is all as not like, like adding mushrooms or adding curcumin or adding, you know,
residual or something like that. This is a drug and it can be hard on your liver.
Typically none of these things, if you added any of these things, are going to be hard on your liver,
okay. Addied mushrooms are not going to be hard on your liver and cause you any issues. But
any Fedbed is all to your protocol can can be hard on your liver. And we have a lot of people that
hasn't done anything to their liver, who had some people that caused upset, tell me and they just
started taking it with food and that solved that problem. But you have to be willing to do a
complete metabolic panel which measures ALT, AstLT in alkaline phosphatase on a very regular basis,
like at least once a month if you're going to do Fedbed is all. Otherwise, I don't think you
should be doing it because you could end up with liver inflammation. I just think you got to be careful.